you're you've been you've been busy
right a little bit yeah I just want to
wish everybody a happy holiday so Gary
except fun what's that let's have fun
whatever you've been doing for your uh I
wrote a book it was called crush it and
did very well I'm very happy with it I
started a consulting company with my
brother AJ who I love more than life and
that's called vaynermedia and we've been
consulting for a lot of big brands the
National Hockey League cadbury Adams and
done some work for sex with Avenue and
Procter & Gamble so that's been
interesting and and I've been doing some
angel investing re lets you yeah that's
been fairly new yesterday you might have
saw gowalla got announced i was in on
that so invested in gowalla a simple geo
dailybooth tumblr oh ya le bouff you
take a picture and it's just a history
of your face as you gold when you lose
your hair for example it reminds you
it's very cool i love it yeah and so
I've uh I've been doing some things I've
been out meeting people I always love to
come to this kind of stuff because I've
already got to meet a lot of people that
I've not met before yeah it's a people
business the week too many people give a
[ __ ] about money and all this horseshit
and metrics and SEO and all this garbage
but it's all about people so yes so so
you know that's why I really wanted to
have you back is we you know you did
your wine show last year and I was
really fun when Libra winery tv.com if
you guys don't know it you have to watch
it gary is becoming the Parker of the
Internet what about that but yeah come
on you there's some people that watch it
it's it's fun as a matter of fact
yesterday night I did a event at a Paris
wine school which was a lot of fun you
know wine wine not only in you know this
is the this is the wine world right this
is where wine does its thing but in the
u.s. people are scared of wine they're
intimidated so I started the show
because I wanted people to try new
things and to trust their own palate
it's not about Parker
me or wine spectator or tradition I mean
Bordeaux we all love bored out but
really we're still completely influenced
by something that happened in eighteen
fifty five I mean things change you know
Tara's terroir but you know winemakers
and things change and so my passion is
to get people to trust their own palette
by the way not only in wine but in
business there's way too many people
looking at all the pretty faces in the
crowd I know for a fact in my heart that
ninety-five percent of the people in
this room don't love what they do one
hundred percent no love this room well
how many people in this room love what
they do 100 whoa whoa whoa one hundred
percent okay so you know what you're
wrong twenty percent no VC severe that
was 21 at max that was maybe not okay
one more time how many know what don't
[ __ ] one hundred percent love what
they do the week that's okay 30 offer I
use that look V seized by the way this
is on camera so I'm sorry this is not 20
fine how many people are not one hundred
percent happy raise your hand ten
percent that's not two percent but fine
listen the fact that matter is my hope
is that people recognize how big the
social shift is right now how the cost
of getting involved and building a
business around what you love is so low
lip gonna head up so you guys if you're
not if you raise your hand the second
time you just stop what you're doing and
you do what you love that's your point
no because you have to be practical you
have to you know pay the mortgage you
have student loans there's practicality
but the fact of the matter is I don't
want people not doing what they love
when they can come home and instead of
at eight o'clock at night or nine
o'clock at night play Nintendo Wii or
drink six beers or watch lost season two
on DVD I want them to start building a
business around what they love because
the cost is zero okay so tell me how I
do that that's your book right well
that's the book but I don't really want
to talk about the book already no
because what i want to talk about what
exactly well i do want to talk about the
jets all the time no we don't that well
we have we have some time we have some
time but what I think it well I know you
probably want to ask some questions
right no go ahead no but you ask a
question first
what do you want to talk about consumer
expectation okay so here's what I'm
fascinated by and I'm curious if you
guys have been looking at this or
thinking about this in 1999 when i
launched free shipping for one day on
Wine Library calm people lost their mind
people bought wine for like 30 years
people are like buying wines for their
daughter's wedding when she was like six
years old it was chaos right because it
wasn't something that everybody was
doing at the time wine is heavy so you
know for a lot of people costs three
dollars a bottle to ship the wine for
and so we did this and it became
insanity and everybody lost their
[ __ ] mind right but what's
interesting is over the course of the
last decade free shipping has become
standard it's it becomes something we're
used to what I know is that if any
person in this room flew to a hotel in
any city in the world and they went in
and got their internet and they try to
sign on for the wireless or whatever and
they got dial-up if they heard who couch
that they would [ __ ] their pants they
would call everybody they know and go
this place sucks that's unbelievable we
get very used to things very fast and
what I think is very important to
understand what I think is going to
impact everybody's business in this room
is that consumers are going to expect a
far greater level of customer service
what I know is that like like I tweet
that you suck at 3am right you have to
answer at some level so you know here's
what I know people are gonna come up
here and talk about facebook connect and
the Twitter fire hose and all this [ __ ]
right what I know is this if you don't
care about your customer and if you're
not delivering on actually giving a crap
about them you're gonna lose going
forward because word of mouth has become
so activated we are also connected in a
way that we've never been that here's
what I know small town rules are going
to start to apply and like the baker's
dozen you know the Baker used to give
you 13 donuts and charge you for 12
because he gave a crap if you go to
Whole Foods or Tesco or anybody place
right now and by 13 donuts they're gonna
charge you 30 you're in a country where
we like what's on fine fine fine we know
what you're talking about so that's
right and so what I'm fascinated by you
your name that's right and what I'm
fascinated by is that when I grew up I
didn't expect my favorite sportsman to
come to my house Patrick Ewing from the
Knicks and say you know Gary thank you
so much for supporting the Knicks you
know I didn't expect Prince to like at
reply me and or send me a letter or come
after a concert and shake my hand but
we're living in a day and age now where
the cost of entry for us to engage with
everybody is so low that our expectation
is growing what Oh Cho Cinco is doing
what Zappos created in corporate culture
Tony's here that's right it's probably
crushing it somewhere right now you know
what what's starting to happen is our
expectation what I do for wine fans they
didn't expect Robert Parker or Jancis
Robinson or the owner of Chateau Latour
to care or give back or answer their
email I think that's starting to change
so you crush it by answering every
single email that guy answers every
single emails I try it and it's and you
can't scale it when you're one person I
understand that my inbox has plenty of
things from August in September why
don't you just archive I mean come on
like you you make it a point to answer
to help why you want to help people so
much I'm you know I used to think that I
was driven by being an immigrant i was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union and I came to the US and we lived
in a studio apartment with eight family
members smaller than that stage so my
whole life I thought that I was driven
and I was successful because I was an
immigrant because I know what it tastes
like to have zero I know what it tastes
like to not have toys and games I
understand what work is right but what
I've come to realize recently is that
I'm driven by gratitude I don't think
we're grateful enough I'm grateful I I I
mean it I i was born in a country where
my DNA would have either put me in jail
got me murdered or i'd be one of those
crazy billionaire russian dudes but you
know one of those paying careful we had
a panel in Russia enough I love listen
to my place ron was [ __ ] um big crush it
but I I got lucky I got to leave
communism come to you know the US I I
have the greatest mother in the world
I my dad are you gonna thank your whole
family yeah my dad cuz that's what the
game is my dad dragged my ass into the
liquor store when I was 13 14 and taught
me hard work pay me two bucks an hour to
bag ice for eight hours a day so I'm
driven by gratitude when you have health
of you and your family everything else
is massively secondary I'm very
disgusted by what I saw last year when
the economy got sides the word no well a
little bit but you know what what what I
was really it was cold it's much more
now we can't walk we fixed a few things
you did you did a great job you're
amazing so what I think is um what I
think was very interesting last year was
when the world economy got soft all I
heard in America and plenty places
around the world was oh [ __ ] it's the
depression it's the depression we're
dead yeah we were all dead that was it
you know and nobody was outside eating
food out of the garbage see here's what
happened we've all become very soft you
know everybody wanted to buy a 50 inch
TV screen that December that's why they
were upset by your 29 inch shut the [ __ ]
up and get to work we don't need we
don't need a Nintendo Wii we don't need
a juju we don't need [ __ ] what we need
to do is be happy and the fact that
matter is this that we live in a day and
age you know who I feel bad for the
people that are just like us the
entrepreneurs and business people just
like us journalists just like us who
lived in a day and age where the
gatekeepers control the game when cash
rules everything around me cream you
know that is who I feel bad for who I
feel great for is every person in this
room because we live in a world where
the platform not [ __ ] Facebook or
Twitter or tumblr the internet that
thing the internet that's 15 years old
by the way the consumer Internet is only
15 years old the [ __ ] thing hasn't
had sex yet and it's dominating
the fact that every person in this room
for very low cost which is by the way 0
sweat a lot of hard work but when did
building a business not take a [ __ ] load
of work I promise you all your
grandparents that built businesses they
didn't get VC funding and talk about
users they built real businesses and it
took a long time the fact that every
person in this room can use the internet
and build a platform and I don't give a
[ __ ] if you live in Silicon Valley or
France or New Jersey everybody's got a
shot the cost is zero that to me means
we're living in the best time ever where
everything's being exposed ustream is
putting out live I mean you're not gonna
even advising people works fezius you
think Tiger Woods is an extreme example
everybody's gonna get called out
everybody nobody's gonna be hiding
anywhere because everything's gonna be
exposed and the fact that we can all
build a real business and the cost of
entry is so low I feel bad for the
entrepreneurs from the 50s and 60s and
40s who didn't have that the
entrepreneurs in the 80s who needed a
hundred thousand dollars to start up a
business the fact that you could start a
business now create content around that
and then back end it if you want to open
a coffee shop a retail coffee shop start
a coffee blog get your [ __ ] hands
dirty and get involved in every coffee
community online stay up to three
o'clock in the morning build real
relationships not spam [ __ ] have people
give a crap about you and when you open
your coffee shop guess what's going to
happen you're gonna be a little bit
better you're gonna have a few more
customers that blueprint is in play and
we as a human race not san fran or New
York or France or Europe we collectively
are under estimating how big this is I
promise you it's so blatantly obvious we
are under estimating how big this shift
is how big this opportunity is it's a
gold rush it's a land grab and there's
gonna be a lot of winners it's not just
one winner this is an Oprah you don't
need to be the Oprah of wine you could
be the hollow or the Ricki Lake or the
Sally Jessy Raphael the 57th best
blogger around exercising is going to be
just okay they're going to do great
because what's happening is traditional
media's money is starting to go away see
since I started vaynermedia and I'm
working with Fortune 100 and fortune 500
companies these people want to spend
money in different places they know it I
mean really TV Nielsen ratings there's a
box in every 6,000 homes and that's the
stats in a day and age where we know
when people sneeze while they're on the
computer it's crazy things are shifting
money's coming down the week there's a
half a trillion dollars in the ad
revenue that's coming down see anybody
in this room that's taken marketing
classes and has gone to university knows
that word of mouth converts yeah we
should do exactly the opposite does was
marketing classes that's well worth but
what they've learned in that class was
word of mouth converts right word of
mouth converts in the 80 percentile
eight out of 10 times if you can afford
to buy what your friend tells you you
will buy marketing advertising banners
bus stops twelve percent just give me
one sec twelve percent if you think
about what's happened over the last 36
months with things like Twitter and
Facebook and all the mobile stuff we are
being connected where our murder word of
mouth explodes the biggest Yenta on the
upper east side of manhattan five years
ago eight years ago could tell 40 or 50
of her socialite friends the weirdest
most introverted person living in
minnesota in the basement of his mom's
house can tell 6,000 now that's game
changing Gary one thing is when you
start I you know I know many people
really want to follow your advice and
how do you say crush it crush it crush
it crush it crush it crush it no crush
it crush it that's your book so how do
you start because then you need to leave
your job you need to join titration leak
no you don't here's the [ __ ] i want
people if you're not happy and you want
to build a business around a world of
warcraft or tea or bike riding the fact
is that matter is that most people not
everybody there's single moms with four
kids there's extremes right a wife
passed away and the husband has to work
three jobs there's extremes but a big
chunk of society they're getting home at
seven or eight a night six at night
right the fact that matter is there's a
lot of hours in between 8pm and two in
the morning and if you're not happy you
deserve and you owe to yourself to
[ __ ] work and instead of watching
three hours of television or doing this
with the wii controller for four hours
you can apply it to building a business
there's a real opportunity now is
everybody gonna win no talent you know
content a little bit of luck what I know
is that suppose for example yeah you
loved video I love video to NBC's yeah
remember i remember seesmic i loved it i
used it i love it well i wasn't gonna
fix it yeah well i love video and um i
would he's good I'm not coming back next
year Emma of course you're coming back
she's because half a million users so
every time no good igbt something that's
right no but you know what one of the
chapters am I in my book and one thing
that I've read your book I'm trying to
crush it you know I'm very really hard
no listen I mean one of the things I
respect about you so much is probably
the most important thing to me when
you're an entrepreneur is reactionary
business I vomit in my mouth when people
come to me and say here's our three year
plan three years in this world that we
all live in are you crazy you know three
weeks things change you know Yuri
technium TechCrunch match will you three
weeks the whole game changes you have to
be able to be a reactionary business
person for example for me Mobile is
clearly coming it's here and it's coming
more and more so you know because I
can't do everything some of my
investments simplegeo gowalla are going
in that space because I want to learn I
want to be on the visor eboard I want to
be a part of that because there's so
much coming there um you have to be
reactionary you just have to be so video
give me your water please uh you have
your sexual yeah i don't i'm not sure
you heard of elvis things he's not
scared of that [ __ ] all right go ahead
some people don't you know i'm not
comfortable with the your advising to do
videos you know they don't have your
charisma I'm not advising new video if
you read the book like you said you did
what I said
what I said was you need to know what 1
i'm fascinated by him what I almost
called the book was brand DNA what I
know is that every person in this room
not everybody is the same not everybody
is over the top listen everybody thinks
they have to be like me to be successful
there's plenty of people in the crowd
that hate me because I'm too
over-the-top that's right i curse many
people hurt you I don't have many I've
some but you know you have to be who you
are what I know is that for everybody
that I turn off I'm gonna get in the
trenches and meet them maybe I'll meet
them here one by one by the cheese
stands people really think you're
completely full of [ __ ] yes guys I you
know I I've got it better than a lot of
people you know that he's among give a
tour you know he's like listen yeah he
talks a lot super I built a 70 million
dollar wine retail business you know it
allows me to have a little bit of an
excuse right if you know it's kind of
nice when you did it right it's kind of
nice when I was making you know a
hundred-thousand-dollar years selling
baseball cards when I was 14 years old
and he could say anything you want and
you could disagree but I'd like for
example please you you say you know old
media we don't need you said that no
what I said was I really you said it
sucks I said it sucks with roi i bought
billboards and magazines and taxi tops
for crush it but when they came to me
and said the billboard is fifteen
thousand dollars on a highway I said
[ __ ] you i'll give you two thousand and
they took it see what i know is this i I
I am NOT romanced by new media I don't
care about Facebook or Twitter honestly
I don't even really care that much about
the internet even though that's the game
if people still looked up in the sky and
looked at smoke signals I climb those
rafters right now and do this I care I
care about the message listen I wrote a
book right a lot of people bust my chops
mr. new media why'd you write a book
there were you worried because people
read them you know I mean the fact of
the matter is is that I'm not romance by
anything but the message the platforms
that we deliver them on is irrelevant
which is why I'm so passionate and why I
wanted to talk today about customer
service because I'm telling you Tony
Hsieh Zappos and then Bezos for being
smart enough to buy them are massively
underrated if you read
I promise you when we look back at it
culture DNA and culture is what wins the
game not price in a day and age where
price is so available to us the fact
that Zappos was not the cheapest and I
hate when people say Zappos was great
because they went on Twitter what are
you talking about it's like going on
Twitter it was corporate culture it was
caring more about the consumer than
anybody else that to me is very
fascinating because that's something
that can be scaled by any startup here
the guys who just won this thing stribe
they're gonna be great and all that they
don't win it unless they give a [ __ ] and
the more you care and the more you care
about your users and the more effort you
put into that and don't [ __ ] it the
more upside you have as a company I
firmly firmly believe that in a world
where our word of mouth is so activated
that when you have a good experience or
a bad experience it's gonna travel
dramatically more than three years ago i
actually think we have a big advantage
to corporate large companies because
they cannot change that fast these
twitter you know acid bath that is being
done by all of us twittering about you
know this brand is great these brownies
you know sucks he's really tough to
manage because they cannot answer that
fast so you can think they have tagged
by stress so far you can they have so
much my blog miss bristle know they can
because here's the problem they had the
dollars to do it they just haven't made
the cultural you know decision to go
there when I hear big companies can't do
it because they're too you know they're
too big they have tons of cash they can
absolutely positively hire seven ten
twenty a hundred people the National
Hockey League which is a league a
professional sports league when they
said to me when I told them i want you
to reply and reply to every email and
every facebook wall message every one
you get they looked at me like that's
impossible I'm like [ __ ] I get more
than you on one person and I'm doing it
how can't you do it here's the
difference people don't want to do it
because they don't recognize why it's
valuable to their business because in
the old days our little individual
voices didn't carry enough weight that's
starting to change consumer expectation
is starting to change and when it starts
ringing up on the radar it's going to
become culture what I'm talking about
right now is going to be standard
business
practices in five years because of
necessity I'm just recommending people
to get there first because it is an
absolute differentiator I just want to
say one more thing because we don't that
much time week keep going there
conferences are very interesting to me I
will not be back not a conference what
is it this is a community okay if it's a
[ __ ] community why are we not doing
QA we're all up here talking if it's a
good wait a minute wait a minute if this
is a community why are we all sitting
around here jerking ourselves off and
talking about stuff when I I refuse to
come back next year unless my entire
presentation is QA we could have done
that entirely if you are weak that's
what you know we can all go up here they
can read about this they know that the
real value is I want to do QA all the
time the Gilmore gangs gone up here
Leisha do Q&A we should you know what
let's kick the next act off and let's do
20 minutes of Q&A right I'm not sure
violet blue will appreciate oh yes my
love you the future of sex it's me way
better than this you know what you can
do as well you still two minutes you
just stay with us for the two days in
the corridors and meet everyone no but
honestly I'm being serious if this is a
community and this is an amazing turnout
and you put on an amazing show and and
the food is quite impressive that's why
why I really come and so but but I
honestly think that every presentation
you know one of my big goals for 2010
you can see I'm growing a beard right in
hockey in America when the teams go into
the playoffs [ __ ] sorry they all grow
beards and so 2010 is gonna be a big
beard year for me you know I'm gonna
talk a little less I think I've talked
enough I'm gonna put my head down and
build vaynermedia I'm going to build
corked my wine social network which I'm
passionate about um and and I'm thinking
about launching a conference that's QA
only because I don't because if it is
community we're not engaging enough with
them in my opinion well we're on twitter
we've been you know exchanging a lot
there are actually some participants you
never showed up to his room which i
think is fantastic Louie I'm not busting
your chops i love you and so does
everybody here how many people love
louis raise your hand
how many how many people hate loi raise
your hand too great you did better than
the love your job hit your job um listen
I'm not busting chops what I'm saying is
that I'm very fascinated about QA I
think there needs to be more of this you
know we're all talking about social
media right everybody gets up here and
says engage with your community and then
all we're doing up here is giving a
presentation so I I'm very passionate
about QA so next year we will have you
do only Q&A I'm gonna do QA after there
somebody do you want this guy back
mixture well it looks like still you
know they liked it listen the bottom
line is this I'm very appreciative to be
up here and spend some time with you
guys I'm gonna stick hope to meet a
bunch of you in a crowd after this and I
wish you guys nothing but health and a
great holiday and and thank you very
very much thank you thank you Gary thank
you very much Gary a Q&A next year with
Gary Vee at Gary Vee on twitter if you
don't follow gary put his backpack
facebook.com slash Gary oh that's you
Giry okay twitter.com such Gary Vee
crush it to the book I think we and it's
cool it's really cool what's next pitch
axis TV show or something not yet thank
you thank you so much thank you Gary